- So we a`re excited about the Batman.
We're excited. (audience cheers)
So what can you tell us about it?
You play a penguin.
- I play, yeah, I play Oz.
Who kind of hasn't
embodied the penguin yet,
but is known as the penguin basically,
because he has a bit of
a awkward gate and yeah,
it was, it was amazing. Oh, there it is.
A really extraordinary makeup artist
called Mike Marino kind
of designed the character.
I will say I can,
- Wait, wait what? Wait.
That's not you though.
- Yeah.
- Wait what?
- Wait, what? I didn't see that picture.
- You didn't really?
- Oh my God. I just heard
that you were penguin.
What the hell?
- Oh you haven't seen that?
- That person deserves to win awards!
- Oh, No, no, no. He should. Yeah. Yeah.
- That's you?
- No, it's amazing. It's it's amazing
what he was capable of and
he designed, the whole thing
- I couldn't download the photo last night
and I kept telling her, I was like
I never saw him as penguin.
- It's amazing.
- Oh my God.
- The first time I saw the
makeup was they had done a,
he had done a mold of my face
and, and I saw it on a
screen, Matt Reeves' screen
the director, the writer,
director of the Batman.
He said, you wanna see
what Mike Reno's done?
What he thinks, what he thinks
ours are gonna look like.
And I said, yeah. And
he showed me the screen.
I just, I didn't know it
was going in that direction.
And I went, holy smoke.
And I'd never done
anything like that before.
And I can't claim-
- What kind of time did
it take to look like that?
- Four hours, at the start, four hours.
and then they got it down
to two and it was fine.
'Cause I knew what the,
reward was immense.
And it was
- You're a different human.
- It was extraordinary
Kelly, it was so liberating.
- Did you ever go out in that?
- No, we did-
- I would have gone out in that.
- We did a test
- And then talked (beep)
about Colin Farrell.
- Yeah, yeah see what people really feel.
- Yeah.
- Until You find out, they're like, sorry,
never heard of him. Ooh. Checked ego.
- That would have been
what I would've done.
- That experiment backfired.